tout de suite et la revue de presse
avec vous hélène frade bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour peut lire revue de presse
largement consacré à la guerre en
ukraine avec à la une la souffrance des
civils et l'aisne où les bombardements
de l'armée russe continue à
s'intensifier alors que les
bombardements continue à s'intensifier
sur plusieurs villes du pays assiégée
depuis cinq jours marioupol cette ville
portuaire du sud est de l'ukraine est en
proie à des scènes dévastatrice de
souffrance humaine selon la croix rouge
la souffrance de civils broyé par la
guerre d'après le quotidien suisse le
temps qui montre on le voit des
habitants de mario paul à terre c'était
vendredi lors d'un bombardement de
l'armée russe dans un hôpital marioupol
ville martyre le parisien aujourd'hui en
france évoque la situation est
dramatique des habitants privés d'eau
d'électricité d'espoir après l'échec de
la deuxième tentative d' opérations
d'évacuation prévue hier des civils pris
au piège de la colère de poutine le
quotidien britannique the independent
hunt fait état de la panique des
ukrainiens face aux bombardements russes
comme ici à irbine dans la banlieue nord
de kiev où des soldats ukrainien tente
on le voit de d'aider une famille à fuir
la ville assiégée mais scène hélène qui
provoque une vague d'émotion en europe
il court pour leur vie titre ce matin
plusieurs quotidiens outre manche dont
de sun qui accuse les dix maires poutine
de massacrer des innocents alors même
qu'il tente de fuir comme cette mère et
son enfant toujours à irbine irin que
fut aussi ce père terrifié avec son
enfant dans les bras à la une du daily
mirror sauver les implore le tabloïd qui
rappelle vous l'avez dit que plus d'un
million et demi d'ukrainiens ont déjà
quitté le pays
la crise de réfugiés la plus rapide
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale selon
l'onu le martyre des civils alerte
libération avec ce gros plan sur la main
d'un habitant tué avec sa femme et ses
deux enfants alors qu'ils tentaient de
fuir et repine eux aussi cette famille
décimée symbole de la souffrance
dévastatrice subie par les ukrainiens
d'après la repubblica cette famille
venait tout juste de réussir à franchir
le pont détruit sur la rivière pin et ne
se trouvait plus qu'à quelques
kilomètres quelques mètres des véhicules
d'évacuation aux abords de la ville où
elle aurait finalement été victimes d'un
tir de mortier russe des images et dont
celle ci est l'âne absolument terrible
qui aident le gouvernement ukrainien à
mobiliser l'opinion internationale la
croix raconte comment ces images
permettent aux autorités ukrainiennes
non seulement de galvaniser l'opinion
occidentale mais aussi de développer
avec une énorme efficacité le récit
d'une nation unie face à un envahisseur
en difficulté un pouvoir russe qui lui a
fait le choix de cris nîmes criminaliser
le travail de la presse en russie
faisant ainsi tomber à rideau de fer
informationnel sur tout le pays la
contestation s'exprime malgré tout comme
en témoignent les images vous les avez
montré de manifestants arrêtés à travers
toute la russie diffusé notamment sur le
site du journal d'opposition novaïa
gazeta qui fait état de manifestations
hier à moscou saint pétersbourg et
d'autres villes encore jusqu'à
vladivostok
c'est tout à l'est de la russie la
guerre en ukraine hélène qui intervient
en pleine campagne pour la
présidentielle en france le premier tour
c'est dans 33 jours exactement à la
france où emmanuel macron en grand jeu
des soutiens elle figure observe que le
président semble bénéficier à plein de
l'effet drapeau de l'idée selon laquelle
on ne change pas de capitaine en pleine
tempête ce qui lui permet à la fois
d'engranger donc les soutiens à droite
comme à gauche d'ailleurs à être se
livrer à une campagne minimaliste une
situation qui amène le filière a rappelé
que si la guerre en ukraine assombri
l'horizon elle ne doit pas le rétrécir
en un seul motif je cite car lorsque la
démocratie devient unis dimensionnelle
alors elle se vide de sa substance cette
mise en garde est exprimée pas avec plus
de véhémence encore un parent l'humanité
qui accuse emmanuel macron de chercher à
escamoter le bilan de son mandat par une
campagne éclair et solitaire une
stratégie que le quotidien par soif
comme une façon de tuer le débat
démocratique mais aussi de camoufler
l'agenda libéral d'emmanuel mâcon pour
les cinq prochaines années à l'extrême
droite maintenant toujours en france
eric zemmour a officialisé hier le
ralliement de marion maréchal on la voit
derrière vous hélène bras le bras levé
c'est la nièce de marine le pen la
patronne du rassemblement national et
rival d'eric zemmour dans cette élection
je suis convaincu qu'eric zemmour est le
mieux placé dans l'élection ce n'est pas
qu'une question de sondage c'est une
question de dynamique a justifié marion
maréchal-le pen cité par le parisien
aujourd'hui en france vue par mediapart
le ralliement de marion maréchal-le pen
eric zemmour ne serait pas une surprise
dans la mesure où la candidature de
zemmour serait avant tout la sienne
depuis le départ selon le site d'info à
travers la candidature de zemmour marion
maréchal chercheur est en réalité à se
débarrasser du parti de sa tante marine
le pen dont elle aurait toujours refusé
la ligne national populiste et
économiquement trop à gauche selon elle
l'objectif pauline de marion maréchal
que ses amis résume dans ces termes je
les cite maintenant il s'agit de passer
la démultipliée devises juste il ne
s'agit pas de blesser l'adversaire mais
de le tuer deux buts et l air de but et
le rn si les négociations il doit y
avoir il faut pouvoir les mener en
position de force en mode poutine ya
reddition ou élimination ambiance merci
beaucoup et là